good morning believe nation today's
messages stop worrying and start taking
action over to you Jack LaLanne there
are so many of you students right now
that are watching me listen to me that
worry about because you're getting
prematurely older you have too many
aches and pains your energy and vitality
is not there anymore you know so all of
these things can be controlled because
we know if you exercise every day and we
know if you eat properly again of
minerals and vitamins and protein and
you do something about your food intake
that you are going to keep yourself
young and you're gonna get rid of those
aches and pains and you're gonna be
beautiful and glamorous this is the
truth isn't it so don't worry about
these things do something about it so I
want to do this when you wake up in the
morning and before you go to bed at
night here is something that I want you
to say a little silent prayer to the
good Lord above remember this God grant
me serenity to accept things I cannot
change courage to change things I can
and the wisdom to know the difference
so when old man weary rears its ugly
head figure out if this thing can you do
something about it or can't you do
anything about it you can do something
about and do something about if you
can't then don't worry about it
therefore you'll have no worries
try it it works so last night I went to
bed thinking about an email that I
wanted to write and I'm lying in bed and
I'm tossing them turning and I'm
thinking about what the subjects gonna
be and I'm thinking about what's gonna
be in the message and then I'm kind of
write it in my head and then rewrite it
in my head and then I start thinking
should I send this email out or not
maybe it's too big an idea you know the
person who's receiving this email could
have a major impact on the project that
I'm trying to work on and then I'm
thinking maybe he's gonna say no you
know maybe he's gonna judge me maybe
it's not gonna work out and in these
moments here's what entrepreneurs do
they usually do two things one they
defer right say you know what I'll do it
tomorrow
this big idea this bold thing that you
want to do when you're feeling in the
moment you don't do it you bow down you
take the easy way out and you never go
after that big bold challenging thing
because you're afraid and you say you
know what I'll do it tomorrow and you
wake up the next thing you don't
actually do
the stupid idea I'm not gonna do that
and you continue on with the mediocre
life the second thing is you'll be up
all night worried about it thinking
about it should I send it should I not
send it what happens if I do send how
should I word it should I add a
different subject line should I put a
picture in there you know what if he
says no like you're just constantly
tossing and turning worried about what's
gonna happen and how much time do you
spend worrying about what's going to
happen or what's not gonna happen if you
take a certain action or don't take a
certain action and so what I've gotten
better at and faster at and try to do
over and over and over again is when I'm
in that moment I get up and do something
about it so I got up last night whatever
the kind of time it was 1:00 in the
morning and just wrote the email and if
he doesn't like it forget about it I
don't care I move on to something else
I've never actually been bitten too hard
in the past it's more just a fear that
it's not gonna work out or people are
gonna judge me but it's never come back
to be really negative for me and I think
it's because the intent is always
positive right I'm trying to create some
goodness I may not have the right
execution it may not be the right idea I
may not be the right plan but I'm trying
to create something good and I think
that that intent trumps everything else
and so the next time that you find
yourself in that situation I'd encourage
you to take action do something about it
you have this big idea you're worried
about it may not work out who cares just
take some action towards this attainment
and you'll find that you often surprise
yourself with the goodness that comes
back so the question the day today is I
want to know what are you worrying about
what's keeping you up at night leave my
comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of in special
the TV go